I took my retirement savings and I risked it all and it worked.
When kids were doing other stuff, I was out surfing.
I was like really into video games and, you know, super nerd geek culture stuff.
I think it was my second shoulder surgery, I ended up losing one of my main sponsors.
Even though I had never hosted anything a day before in my life,...
...because of who I was they were able to embrace me.
Whether it's mopping the floors,...
...whether it's painting signs, you really need to get your hands dirty.
I knew I kind of had one chance to give it my all.
It's like I had to make the decision to be who I am.
I went from 101 to number one.
So I'm just gonna keep going.
I never look back.